- [Voiceover] We now
have a lot of experience
finding the areas under
curves when we're dealing
with things in rectangular coordinates.
So we saw we took the Riemann sums,
a bunch of rectangles,
we took the limit as we
had an infinite number of
infinitely thin rectangles
and we were able to find the area.
But now let's move on
to polar coordinates.
And in polar coordinates
I won't say we're finding
the area under a curve,
but really in this example
right over here we have
a part of the graph of
r is equal to f of theta and we've graphed
it between theta is equal to
alpha and theta is equal to beta.
And what I wanna do in
this video is come up with
a general expression
for this area in blue.
This area that is bounded,
I guess you could say
by those angles and the graph
of r is equal to f of theta.
And I want you to come
up, or at least attempt
to come up with an expression on your own,
but I'll give you a
little bit of a hint here.
When we did it in rectangular coordinates
we divided things into rectangles.
Over here rectangles don't
seem as obvious because
they're all kind of coming to this point,
but what if we could divide things into
sectors or I guess we could
say little pie pieces?
Someone is doing some
serious drilling downstairs.
I don't if it's picking
up on the microphone.
But anyway, I will continue.
So what would happen if
we could divide this into
a whole series of kind of pie pieces
and then take the limit as if we had
an infinite number of pie pieces?
So we want to find the
area of each of these pie
pieces and then take the
limit as the pie pieces
I guess you could say
become infinitely thin
and we have an infinite number of them.
And I'll give you one more
hint, for thinking about
the area of these pie, I guess you could
say the area of these pie wedges.
I'll give you another
hint, so if I have a circle
I'll do my best attempt at a circle.
Luckily the plumbing or
whatever is going on downstairs
has stopped for now
allowing me to focus more on
the calculus, which is
obviously more important.
All right so if I have
a circle, that's my best
attempt at a circle, and it's of radius r
and let me draw a sector of this circle.
It's a sector of a circle, so
that's obviously r as well.
And if this angle right
here is theta, what is
going to be the area of
this sector right over here?
So that's my hint for you,
think about what this area
is going to be and we're
assuming theta is in radians.
Think about what this area
is going to be and then
see if you can extend
that to what we're trying
to do here to figure out, somehow
I'm giving you a hint again.
Using integration, finding
an expression for this area.
So I'm assuming you've had a go at it.
So first let's think about
this, what's the area
of the entire circle,
well we already know that.
That's going to be pi r squared,
formula for the area of a circle.
And then what's going
to be the area of this?
Well it's going to be a
fraction of the circle.
If this is pi, sorry if this
is theta, if we went two pi
radians that would be the
whole circle so this is
going to be theta over
two pi of the circle.
So times theta over two pi would be the
area of this sector right over here.
Area of the whole circle
times the proprotion
of the circle that we've kind of defined
or that the sector is made up of.
And so this would give
us, the pis cancel out,
it would give us one half
r squared times theta.
Now what happens if instead of theta,
so let's look at each of these over here.
So each of these things that I've drawn,
let's focus on just one of these wedges.
I will highlight it in orange.
So instead of the angle
being theta let's just
assume it's a really,
really, really small angle.
We'll use a differential
although this is a bit of
loosey-goosey mathematics
but the important here
is to give you the
conceptual understanding.
I could call it a delta
theta and then eventually
take the limit as our delta
theta approaches zero.
But just for conceptual
purposes when we have
a infinitely small or super
small change in theta,
so let's call that d theta,
and the radius here or I guess
we could say this length right over here.
You could view it as the radius of
at least the arc right at that point.
It's going to be r as a
function of the thetas that
we're around right over
here, but we're just going
to call that our r right over there.
And so what is going to be the
area of this little sector?
Well the area of this
little sector is instead of
my angle being theta I'm calling
my angle d theta, this
little differential.
So instead of one half
r squared it's going to
be, let me do that in a color you can see.
This area is going to be
one half r squared d theta.
Notice here the angle
was theta, here the angle
was d theta, super, super small angle.
Now if I wanted to take
the sum of all of these
from theta is equal to alpha
to theta is equal to beta
and literally there is an
infinite number of these.
This is an infinitely small angle.
Well then for the entire
area right over here
I could just integrate all of these.
So that's going to be the
integral from alpha to
beta of one half r
squared d theta where r,
of course, is a function of theta.
So you could even write it this way,
you could write it as
the integral from alpha
to beta of one half r of
theta squared d theta.
Just to remind ourselves or assuming r
is a function of theta in this case.